someone so cold-hearted supporting
Douglas Murray when Matty Hassan
absolutely destroyed him shows you what
kind of V individuals were dealing with
if they had the power they would kill us
with their own
hands do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has helped develop all of
us it's extremely beneficial to do this
course definitely recommend this course
to access the free lifechanging training
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends when Allah says in the Quran we
did not believe it until we can see it
for ourselves now this doesn't mean that
our efforts should that we should have
efforts with individuals like Jordan P
mm and ham and many other people who try
to you know give the Olive Branch the
olive tree to U show him Islam Etc but
Allah tells us to never take them as
intimate friends here is the message
that a tweet uh that this absolute dirt
bag I'm going to call it the dirt bag of
the dirt uh Subhan Allah said or tweeted
about Mii Hassan I see you got nicely
humiliated by Douglas Mari last night in
Toronto at the monk debate M Hassan it
couldn't have possibly happened to
someone more deserving I mean if this
was true you can say okay this didn't
even happen meth had absolutely owned
and humiliated Douglas mared this scum
dirt it just just I don't know maybe
have you ever been there yes when a few
years ago not recently I didn't I didn't
I don't get awards from the president
Isel like you so I don't get to do
soft I didn't get inv
into let me finish my point let me to
Gaza right you said you went to Gaza how
come you went to Gaza when the world's
media is not allowed into Gaza they took
you into Gaza well first of all I'll
explain I'll explain but let me pick up
my point now this Jordan Peterson the
bastard he is a bastard why you need to
understand guys we've gone past the
stage of like yeah you know listen I'm
not fake I'm not going to try to be
something I'm not all of these zionists
are bastards to me they are scumbags
they these anyways I don't say
uh stuff that might get myself in
trouble anyways you can see what does
Allah subh say in the Quran look at this
scum dirt bag this absolute bastard
seeing the killing of innocent people
and what did he say give them help you
can see that they only care about
themselves they don't care the Muslim
blood is cheap how could someone who has
an atom weight of heart sympathy mer
Mercy that Allah subhana wa tala has put
inside us see the killing of Palestinian
children and still support an individual
like dougas maray what does Allah tell
us in the Quran we would only learn like
this when Allah says we don't Allah say
in
Quan yes which is what Allah says oh
Believers take neither the Jews nor
Christians as Guardians intimate friends
they are Guardians to one another that
is exactly the H and the truth this
doesn't mean we do not have friends that
are Christians or Jews do not take them
as intimate friends cuz when push comes
to shove they pick their sight very
simply and we can see the Christian
Lobby supporting who Zionist and it's
actually funny why they doing this
because they want the end times to come
so when Jesus comes he will go kill all
the Jews can you imagine this they're
like we supporting you until Jesus comes
and he's going to get rid of all of you
and what the Jews saying they're saying
yeah yeah carry support on us because
when our Messiah comes we're going to
get rid of you Gentiles yeah you can see
the each other's dismay that's all I
wanted to say Subhan Allah Allah subh
T's word is H the more we take what
Allah subh T says before we learn with
our own lesson except see for ourself
the quicker we will learn Allah subhana
tal is the best of planets when he says
something he says it for a reason trust
his judgment have and trust in him
brothers and sisters may Allah subhana
tal deal with this scum Jordan bastard
this Jordan pet not Jord bastard that's
what his name is inah may Allah subhana
deal with him may Allah subhana make him
feel worse when want Palestinians are
going through I wish that upon Him
someone so coldhearted supporting
Douglas maray when mat has an absolute
Destro him shows you what kind of VI
individuals were're dealing with that if
they had the power they would kill us
with their own hands I believe this
truly brother and sisters may Allah subh
keep you guys firm